[Music]
want to do a bit of an exercise sure
okay and then you know if you don't like
it just tell me when was the last this
is something I do in my groups or when I
speak or in a song when I teach so yes I
ask people to tell me some recent
episode whenever said with somebody with
their lives and something that they were
open to sharing so it doesn't have
anything sordid everything but just
something out whether it's your spouse
partner the bus driver
I don't care sure a friend okay so I
used to go there anything okay I can
share anything just where you upset with
somebody okay yes okay so what happened
describe it what happened yeah alright
there were a number of issues in my home
broken aspects of the home things that
were falling apart or needed to be fixed
physically physically okay yeah right
and I had hired someone to do these
things right while I was gone
okay and I came back and none other more
fixed okay and your emotional reaction
was anger rage anger okay anything else
besides anger hmm I think they're close
cousins frustration first fishness
frustration is anger yeah yep was
disappointed disappointed his sadness
yeah it's a different feeling so I was
disappointed myself also because I
started to look at how maybe well
disappointed is not so much an emotion
as a state of mind and asking what the
emotions were I'm like what's inside
disappointment something didn't happen I
wanted to happen how do I feel there's
no sadness there sure yeah there's
sadness I'm not talking into it I'm just
asking well I suppose um I might be
confusing state of mind and states of
mind and emotions I'm not sure I look at
the raw emotion yeah sadness
so there's anger and sadness those are
the emotions let's let's go with that
okay so I'm gonna ask you a silly
question what we've said in angry about
well I suppose the answer which is not
the right answer I'm expecting was I was
angry that someone had made commitments
to me and not fulfill those commitments
okay what that's what happened they had
made the commitment um but that doesn't
tell me what you were sad or angry well
what does that mean that they didn't
fulfill their commitments uh meant that
they didn't care about me they didn't
have that they disrespect me so they
didn't care about you didn't respect you
what kind of person doesn't get carried
or respected mmm I might need a lifeline
here I don't know someone who doesn't
deserve to be cared for our perspective
exactly
somebody unworthy right sure will
respect them and and care okay know if
two other people here which they usually
are when I do this exercise I would ask
them okay we just listened to Tim tell
us about this experience are there other
reasons why this other person might not
have done the work that has nothing to
do with him or her not caring about him
or not respecting him so what are the
reasons might there be a million in one
name one yeah he could have he could be
in the hospital her dark-haired one
could have been in a car accident
exactly he had a flight delaying a
caught on Puerto Rico during a hurricane
him yeah he's got ADHD yeah he and he
can't follow through he's under stress
and he couldn't write you know the email
that I was supposed to send us sitting
in drafts and I thought I'd sent it but
in fact you never received it I mean
okay and any number of possibilities
ya know of all the possibilities that
you've just outlined including that he
they don't care about your respect you
which is the worst one the one I
immediately defaulted to right well I
mean the worst
yeah internally the worst assumption
that's the one that I immediately
exactly so let's notice something hey
you I should say we because we're all
like this we don't respond to what
happens we respond to a perception of
what happens right okay
that's what the Buddha said it's with
our minds who create the world so that
if you'd found that ADHD or or you were
stressed or you know you might have been
sad for him boy would not have been
angry and you will not have been sad
okay you might you know so first of all
we don't respond to what happens we
respond to our perception of what
happens to our interpretation of times
number one number two of all the
possible interpretations we choose the
worst one yep number two thirdly what I
just said isn't true we didn't choose it
it's not like you went through all these
possibilities option no he doesn't care
about me he doesn't respect me you
didn't do that your brain jump there
automatically right my question is why
yep now here's the learning first time
in your life that you felt hurt and
angry that you when you perceive
somebody didn't care about you or didn't
respect you or has it happened before
this is where the exercise might might
might go sideways I'm gonna hit pause on
that I think that's probably for more of
a conversation over wine but you
probably agreed it's not the first time
it's not the first time very good and
most people I talk to
it goes back way back yeah this goes way
back and into childhood mmm okay and
that's what's wrong way is we don't
respond to the present moment we respond
to the past no but along the lines of
our discussion it's a beautiful learning
opportunity no you get to know now what
if you assume for a moment that you're
the most lovable most worthy of care
most worthy of respect person in the
history of the universe and this guy
doesn't do your own what's your response
any number of the other options which
does not trigger their an intense
negative emotional stare so there's
other options would trigger that so
something in use I would argue
still believes that you're not worthy of
care and respect and that's what gets
triggered so who's the one that doesn't
care about you and who's the one that
doesn't think you really respect that
would be me you yeah no that's a
learning notice and this is exactly what
you're talking about you're saying how
these difficult things how these
problems are always teaching
opportunities and that's the beauty of
healing is that when you reframe things
and you and you actually see the source
within ourselves all of a sudden that's
liberating because guess what if you're
feeling that way because this guy did
this or didn't do that that makes you a
victim yeah but if you see that you are
the source ya know you're powerful
you